today we're here for a lunch and we want
to be treated like a normal customer
actually was do it which makes the best
thing in Francis to Eddie Knight to
leave you in the hands of one of our
noble waitresses and they create a kit
for them
unknown Tofino my PA jennifer is also
dining here and once again to offer a
secret perspective on the restaurants
performance one of the first dishes to
arrive is chipper oneis deep fried baby
squid I have a plate please
I said I'm going away all right yeah
ager but I tell you what there is a way
with hammock assault up quite a lot of
salt over seasoning is once again a
problem and just keen to get to the root
of the issue now with the physic their
seasoning but what was I like to have I
believe you mr. Lomax because any one
thing is the chip really cool a bit
sauces every dish that goes up on the
par sheepish extra salt pepper over and
I said don't they finish it off
themselves Jews no no but I had a bit
more about tasting it is make sense you
gotta trust your chassis yes
we told the restaurant that we're on an
hour's deadline but the main still take
forty minutes to arrive just just dip
your fingers cold
this should be called but the problem
with the pork belly is not just the
temperature so part of it far too many
other it's really overpowering it's like
going to the dentist when anesthetic
their finest hour
now for that one we have to leave in
just five minutes and still no one's
taken out deserve orders
we're running votes heights of time
could you recommend something quick pre
desserts and what would you we're out of
time we have to go that's why I asked me
to choose sweet quick desserts
no difficult two seconds please I'd like
the bill I like salmon Eddie please
thank you so much
damn that's a shame
I have to be honest I'm disappointed
because it's nowhere near as good as it
was last time round there's a strand of
over seasoning food that is being cooked
by the brigade and re seasoned by the
chef before it goes what I'm more
nervous about is the sloppy service I
think what's interesting is look people
keep looking around the room is the
tables who obviously weren't trying to
test her tests on the service you know
because I've seen ionize was good and
the quality the food was good
Eddy's bold claim is about to be put to
the test by my PA Jennifer how was lunch
we have some mixed feedback we felt that
the welcome needed work the staff seemed
preoccupied at the beginning and we felt
a little abandoned I thought that the
stuffed project flour with the goat's
cheese was a triumph it looked pretty
acerbic a suit and a taste was divine
however towards the ends when the
restaurant became extremely busy
unfortunately the service tailed off and
we began to feel neglected and in fact
our team coffee order was at the bottom
we've said before we like to be the best
we like to win and obviously it's not a
great day when when it when it goes
wrong
carpet suddenly mean taken out from
under our feet and that's not a good
feeling my last experience here was near
flawless and it was almost on the verge
of perfection that was embarrassing